president Trump's support base is not
going to erode anytime soon while the
media fulminated over Donald Trump
Junior's reported meeting with then
campaign manager Paul Manafort and from
son-in-law Jared Kushner and Russian
connected lawyer in June 2016 and while
they mock president Trump's overtures to
Russian dictator Vladimir Putin they
largely ignored the importance of one
image and one image only for Trump's
followers the image came on Saturday
when President Trump approached marine
one at the end was Air Force Base a
strong wind knocked the hat off the head
of a Marine standing closest to the
staircase onto the helicopter because
the marine could not move he was
standing at attention
Trump retrieved the Hat and put it back
on the Marines head to have to off again
and again Trump went retrieved the Hat
this may have seemed like a big nothing
to the left but it means a lot people on
the right who filled the Obama White
House routinely ignored the dignity of
our troops
President Obama brags openly about using
troops as a photo-op he forced Marines
to hold an umbrella over him as he gave
a statement in the rain outside the
White House he planned some friendly
troops at pre-screened events and of
course Obama's Veterans Affairs
administration was a full-scale disaster
the same weekend from help to this
marine with the Tet we found out that
500 VA officials had been fired by the
Trump administration for malfeasance and
herein lies the point because our
politics have become so little about
policy and so much about intent Trump's
most ardent supporters are never going
to abandon him whether they believe that
he's actually making America great again
they think he wants to make America
great again and they think Obama didn't
want to make America great again in that
assessment they're 100% correct but that
also means that the media's attempts to
play trumpet a nefarious Russian stooge
manipulating the system to his own
benefit that's going to fall on deaf
ears
Trump is seen by his supporters as it
reactions the America last attitude of
his predecessors supporters are not
going to believe that Trump's
america-first attitude is secretly Trump
first video like the marine one tape
reinforced the Trump support is that it
believes that stuff so long as Trump
continues to demonstrate his obvious
reverence for American symbols it will
be very very difficult for the left to
carve into his base I'm here oh this is
the Ben Shapiro show
all righty so welcome to our new Studios
getting magnificences they are there's a
whole other wall that you're not even
gonna get to see yet but it's just
amazing it's amazing it has gadgets and
it's made of gold and they're dancing
women and everything but you won't see
that wall yet that's that's if you
actually purchase the subscription any
case we have we have lots coming up on
today's show I want to talk about
obviously the hubbub surrounding Donald
Trump jr. I want to talk about Trump and
Putin I also want to show you the tape
of Trump doing this with the marine tax
I think that it actually does speak to
why so many conservatives really like
from but before I get to any of that I
want to say thank you first to our
friends and sponsors over at blue apron
blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the country so here's how it works
you go on and you subscribe to blue
apron and then they send you a meal
right and every meal is $10 per person
for a delicious meal under $10 per
person for every delicious meal they
send you all the ingredients they're
always fresh they're guaranteed fresh
and then you cook it right there at home
so you don't have to go out to a
restaurant it's delivered to your door
these are gourmet quality meals I mean
we are talking upcoming meals seared
chicken and creamy pasta salad with
summer squash and sweet peppers fresh
basil fettuccine pasta with sweet corn
and cubanelle pepper chili butter steaks
and Parmesan potatoes and spinach Minh
it sounds absolutely phenomenal and they
don't repeat recipes unless you want
them to cooking together builds strong
family bonds and it's a lot more
inexpensive than going out to a
restaurant those who spend a lot of
restaurants or high-end grocery chains
can spend under $10 per person for one
of these meals so it is affordable
there's variety because a bunch of new
recipes every single week it's
flexibility you can customize your
recipes every single week based on
preference delivery options you can
choose what fits your needs and it's
guarantee that every ingredient is going
to be delivered ready to cook or they
will make it right they have a freshness
guarantee check out this week's menu get
your first three meals free with free
shipping by going to blue apron comm
slash Shapiro again first three meals
for free so you personally you get three
meals by for your family you get three
meals for your family or three meals for
each person one meal for each person in
the family we have three members of your
family with free shipping by going to
blue apron calm slash up here oh you
will love how good it feels and it
tastes to make fresh food in your own
house blue apron calm slash appear
everybody in LA is using it I just heard
wonderful rave
views from everybody who has blue apron
comm flash of hero and remember if you
do that then you get those first three
meals for free with free shipping at
blue apron comm slash Shapiro okay so
lots going on over the weekend I will
play you the tape of me on get made some
news of me on Dana fariñas show on Fox
News that happen on Friday evening
before Sabbath for me and I was debating
a member of care the Council on
american-islamic relations will play
that a little bit later I also do want
to get to the the Linda Sarsour column
in The Washington Post which is just
absurd but we start today with all of
the hubbub over Donald Trump jr. so
yesterday late yesterday there's a story
that breaks in the New York Times and
what it says is the president Trump's
eldest son Donald Trump jr. was promised
damaging information about Hillary
Clinton before agreeing to meet with a
Kremlin connected Russian lawyer during
the 2016 campaign according to three
advisors to the White House briefed on
the meeting and two others with
knowledge of it the meeting was also
attended by the president's campaign
chairman at the time Paul Manafort
and his son-in-law Jared Kushner mr.
Madoff Orton mr. Krishna recently
disclosed the meeting though no it's not
its content and confidential government
documents described to the New York
Times so okay
Trump jr. then makes a statement after
this story breaks and he he originally
had said there were no meetings with the
Russians then he said well we did have a
meeting with some Russian gal but it was
really more about adoption policy than
it was about anything else and then
finally he released a statement late
yesterday in which he said the reason
that we met with this random Russian
lawyer is because she promised that she
had some dirt on Hillary Clinton right
he actually admitted that so here is his
statement Donald Trump jr. statement
that he provided to ABC News late
yesterday quote I was asked to have a
meeting by an acquaintance I knew from
the 2013 Miss Universe pageant with an
individual where I was told might have
information helpful to the campaign I
was not told her name prior to the
meeting I asked Jared and Paul to attend
but told them nothing of the substance
we had a meeting in June 2016 after
pleasantries were exchanged the woman
stated she had information that
individuals connected to Russia were
funding the Democratic National
Committee and supporting miss Clinton
her statements were vague ambiguous and
made no sense no details or supporting
information was provided or even offered
it quickly became clear that she had no
meaningful information
she then changed subjects and began
discussing the adoption of Russian
children and mentioned the Magnitsky Act
that is an anti
rushon it's a Russian sanctions Act it
became clear to me that this was the
true agenda all along and that the
claims of potentially helpful
information were a pretext for the
meeting I interrupted an advice from my
father was not an elected official but a
private citizen and that her comments
and concerns were better addressed if
and when he held public office the
meeting lasted approximately 20 to 30
minutes okay so lots of open questions
about this meeting okay then there are
similar trick questions to be asked
about this meeting first of all what you
need to understand about this lawyer
they met with is that the lawyer is very
close with the Russian government so
according to The Washington Post today
they talk about who this lady is
and essentially she worked closely with
somebody who works with during the 2013
Miss Universe pageant so according to
the Washington Post from junior's did
not name the acquaintance who fixed up
the interview but in an interview Sunday
Rob Goldstone a music publicist friendly
with the Crump jr. told the Post that he
had arranged the meeting at the request
of a Russian client and had attended it
along with this woman whose name was a
vessel it's gaia vessel and it's kaya
okay so her client role okay this woman
vessel Mnet's kaya her client role
includes individuals and companies close
to the kremlin she's for the past
several years basically been a lobbyist
for the russian government on the
Magnitsky act Magnitsky act is a
sanctioned series intended to rebuke
russian for human rights abuses
according to the post the acronym for
Sergei Magnitsky a Russian lawyer who
died under mysterious circumstances in a
Moscow prison so basically the story is
that somebody who Trump jr. knew from
the 2000 Miss Universe pageant
approached him said I know this lady
that's on that's kaya and she has some
information about Hillary Clinton that
you're going to want to know and Trump
jr. dragged metaphor and and Jared
Kushner into the meeting and nothing
came of it right that's sort of the the
most innocent version of the story now
there are a couple questions one did
Trump jr. know that this vessel Mnet's
kaya character was actually connected to
the Russian government like where did he
get information about her we don't know
that yet we just don't know and one of
the reasons that we don't know any of
that is because nobody has been very
forthcoming about it right we don't know
if she's just a private citizen who's
tight with the Russian government we
don't know from junior knew anything
about her he says he didn't know even
know her name right he says I was not
told her name prior to the meeting which
begs the question why would you drag the
three top officials in the Trump
campaign at that time into a meeting two
days after
had secured the nomination essentially
with a Rando right if I wanted to get a
meeting with Trump jr. and and Manta
Ford and Jared Kushner presumably it
would be difficult for me to get that
meeting like you have to make a pitch so
what was the pitch the left is adjusting
the pitch was somebody came to Trump jr.
and said listen there's this lady who
basically represents the Russian
government the Russian government has
dirt and this is the fulfillment of all
the lofty dreams right that's the
Pillman's of all the left you dreamed is
that Trump jr. got Manta for dinner in a
room all of them to hear dirt from the
Russian government on Hillary Clinton
that is not perfectly drawn yet right
there is no evidence that that is the
case yet because again we don't know
number one how close she is with the
Russian government this warrior and
number two what they were told we just
don't know right we'd have to actually
get their emails or their text we'd have
to get the phone call material leading
up to the meeting to know how bad any of
this really is but the left of course
thinks this is a massive massive
bombshell and they're playing it as such
CNN is running with it
of course unit is running with it
because CNN only gets ratings whenever
they talk about Trump Russia and they
have something new to report
so Michael Walsh over at the New York
Post a guy whose work I think is pretty
Hermus he has a critique of the of this
particular story and he says so what
races who wouldn't meet with a Kremlin
connected Russian lawyer during the 2016
campaign he says just as the Russian
collusion fantasy a resentful smear
cooked up in the immediate aftermath of
Clinton's stunning defeat last fall was
finally fading from the fever swamps of
the resistance and its media mouthpieces
along comes the time with a pair of
journalistic noting burgers and he says
that this is a nothing burger because no
campaign in its right mind would turn
down an offer of information on their
opponent this is what Oppo research is
all about
you can bet Hillary wouldn't have hung
up on the person who claimed to have
dirt on the Donald okay so that's
probably true but we would have cried
bloody murder right if the Russians had
approached Hillary Clinton says we and
said we have dirt on Donald Trump and
she had met with the Russians we would
have said okay this is insane because
obviously that's the quid so what's the
pro quo right if you're handing
information from the Russians what is
the pro quo and you know Sean Hannity
came out last night and he was tweeting
about how all the could the Clinton said
all these corrupt things and there were
no consequences right and we all cried
about it we said it was terrible so we
can't have a different standard when it
comes to President Trump so I don't
really buy Michael Walsh's
defense here you know again I think the
best defense here is just ignorance as
always the best defense here is
ignorance which is why lawyers always
tell people your first rule on the stand
is I don't recall but we don't know
enough for the suit to really go
anyplace yet but the media is going to
overplay it it's fascinating the way
that the Republicans are treating this
so Reince Priebus who's the White House
chief of staff he's on TV yesterday and
he made that he promoted the theory
which had been pushed on a website
called circa that Russian operative set
up the meeting is basically a sting for
Donald Trump jr. and Manafort and
Kushner here's Bryon's cribs making that
case on the January 8th edition of Fox
News Sunday Chris Wallace asked Priebus
point-blank does he accept that the
Russians were behind this hacking
campaign yes or not well sure I mean
he's not denying that that entity is in
Russia and it were behind this
particular hacking campaign however the
incoming White House chief of staff then
seemed to place at least some of the
blame on the Democrats saying we have
the DNC as a sitting duck if the DNC
allows any foreign entity into their
system well voila now you have the
biggest dissemination of emails that
we've ever seen in the history of
America previous was then pressed about
who was really to blame and he admitted
the primary actor is the foreign entity
that's perpetrating the crime to begin
with no doubt about it in the past Trump
has expressed skepticism about Russian
hacking claims at one point saying it's
a very hard thing to prove while later
calling it a political witch-hunt okay
but then previous went on to repeat the
Circa statement and that's the important
part
the circus statement was basically the
Russian operatives meeting with Trump
jr. and mana fort and Kushner in order
to set up a Singh the problem is that
were true why exactly wouldn't they just
reveal that right if they actually
wanted to get Trump wouldn't they reveal
that somewhere during the campaign or
now right the Kremlin is now denying
this meeting ever took place so is this
more smoke but no fire I think it is I
think it's more smoke but no fire yet
again I don't know why exactly top Trump
campaign officials would be meeting with
a Russian lawyer for a non nefarious
purpose here but I'm not going to by
Michael Walsh's routine either where he
says who wouldn't meet with an Apple
researcher claiming to have ties with
the Russian government even if that were
true okay in in 2000 Al Gore who is no
Paragon of morality in 2000 somebody
leaked
the Bush briefing book the Bush debate
briefing book - Al Gore and Al Gore's
people promptly called the FBI ok so
it's not true that everybody's engaged
in this sort of stuff now again are the
media getting ahead of themselves of
course are they treating a meeting that
had no actual outcome as the beginning
and end of all things yes I mean even if
all of this is true what we have here is
a meeting that was failed right it's not
it's not natural quid pro quo if there
was not even a quid right if they didn't
actually give any information to the
Trump campaign then there's no
information that the media is treating
this as though a second step is
guaranteed that basically the meeting
happened Trump jr. and Nana fort may not
have gotten anything but then that's
where the coordination began but there's
no evidence this is where the
coordination began maybe it was a
one-off maybe as the Russians trying to
make a contact in order to muddy the
waters we just don't know and so
everybody is going you know over-the-top
about a report I think that has very
little substance to it as of yet well
meanwhile you know President Trump isn't
doing himself any favors with all of the
of the Russia stuff so over the weekend
there's a lot of talk about what exactly
Trump had said in his meeting with
Vladimir Putin Syria called late last
week Trump met at the g20 with the
Russian dictator and coming out of the
meeting President Trump
essentially said that he had gotten
along well with Putin that Putin had
brought up the election hacking stuff to
Putin and that Putin had denied it and
then he said we're going to move forward
together he sends out a series of tweets
on Sunday that through his entire
administration and a bit of turmoil so
it started off I strongly pressed
President Putin twice about Russian
meddling in our election he vehemently
denied it I've already given my opinion
okay so start with that he's already
given his opinion so again his opinion
is apparently that there was some
Russian hacking but it also might've
been the Chinese and a 400-pound guy in
a bed somewhere so kind of unclear what
he means by that then he says we
negotiated a ceasefire in parts of Syria
which will save lives now it's time to
move forward in working constructively
with Russia but didn't stop there he
continued Putin I discussed forming an
impenetrable cybersecurity unit so that
election hacking and many other negative
things will be guarded okay so this is
the this is a tweet to got everybody
going was okay if Trump really believed
that the Russians were behind the the
election involvement and interference
why is he forming a cybersecurity unit
with them this is like marsh
Clark says to OJ Simpson you're guilty
of murdering your ex-wife and he says no
no never Dennis you know what I'm going
to form a joint task force with you OJ
Simpson to go and track down the person
who actually murdered your ex-wife a lot
of people who are making fun of this
yesterday as well they should because
the idea of forming a cybersecurity unit
with the people who are basically
attempting to hack democratic
institutions is really quite crazy and
then Trump continues along these lines
he says and safe questions were asked
about why the CIA and FBI had to ask the
DNC 13 times for their server and were
rejected still don't and then he
continues habit faking news said 17
Intel agencies when actually four you
had to apologize why did Obama do
nothing when he had info before election
so all of this is if he's attempting to
say I took election hacking super
seriously and then I and then I put the
screws to Putin this little tweet storm
is not exactly it's not exactly assuring
people it's not making people feel very
reassured about all of us so you know he
ripped Obama he ripped the fake news as
for Putin he says I've already said what
I'm going to say we're going to form a
cybersecurity unit okay well there's a
bunch of fala and then later that
evening like 12 hours later Trump comes
back with his final tweet right 12 hours
later he comes back sanctions were not
discussant in use - sorry along UN
forces sanctions we're not discussing my
meeting with President Putin nothing
will be done until the Ukrainian and
Syrian problems are solved so I'm not
getting rid of any of the sanctions but
I'm not increasing the sanction okay so
the cybersecurity thing is what got
people all hot and bothered later in the
day he came back and he said the fact
that President Putin and I discussed a
cybersecurity unit doesn't mean I think
it can happen it can but a cease fire
can and did okay well I'm glad that he's
coming to the fight though the right
conclusion about cyber security but he
sent all of his people out all day
talking about how he was actually going
to form a cybersecurity and it just
shows that there's a bit of confusion at
the top with regard to what President
Trump actually believes about all of
this and it isn't reassuring to people
if you're trying to promote an image of
yourself as a guy who is independent of
Russia this is not the way to do it but
I'll tell you what I think is actually
really going on first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at car
shield so if you are if you are on the
road and your car breaks down it could
cost you 100 even thousands of dollars
to fix particularly if you have the
owner
a used car that's why I recommend
getting extended vehicle service
protection from car shield okay so all
of these parts that are broken can cost
you as much as the the cost of a new car
instead get covered by car shield the
ultimate and extended vehicle service
protection it's affordable protection
that can save you thousands for a
covered repair and it's not just
mechanical repairs we're talking
computer GPS electronics even if simple
repair to a sensor can cost over a
thousand dollars but you can get all of
that fixed right now with car shield
just go it over to car shield and sign
up today you get the VIP treatment also
from car shields administrators which
means 24/7 roadside assistance you no
longer need Triple A you get a rental
car while yours is in the shop save
yourself from those terrible repair
bills and get covered by car shield
before something goes wrong go to car
shield calm /pun car shield on / bending
you save 10% that's car she'll calm /
Bend again that's car shield calm / been
a deductible may apply go over to car
shield calm and make sure that you are
protected from the vicissitudes of your
own vehicle so if Trump is trying to
show so the media are basically trying
to claim that Trump is a traitor they
have been ever since Hillary Clinton was
defeated and even before that they're
trying to claim that Putin was was
Trump's puppet master and Trump was the
puppet and now President Trump should be
drawing distance and in Poland he
started to do that ready to give a great
speech in which she talked about Western
civilization and he talked about the
importance of standing up to Russia in
Ukraine and he called out Russia on
Syria and then he has a meeting with
Putin and it basically looks like he got
rolled it looks like he came out and the
only things that happened where he comes
out and rips his own intelligence
community he rips the media he rips the
Democrats and then he's pretty kind of
Putin he says will sign a cease-fire and
then he says we'll have a cybersecurity
unit where we cooperate and then finally
does what we won have a cybersecurity
that's kind of dumb it doesn't mean I
think it can happen it can't really
happen
but we can have a ceasefire so we can
still be best friends
of course these sort of mixed signals do
not assure now what I actually I want to
tell you a little bit more than mixed
signals but then I want to tell you what
I think is actually happening here so
first on the on the mixed signals Corey
Lewandowski who of course is still close
to president Trump there's talk about
him reentering that the White House he's
a former campaign manager for Trump he
says listen the Russians say they didn't
hack and so that's basically the end of
the story what we saw yesterday and
what's been reported yesterday is that
the president took this
directly to Vladimir Putin questions in
if they were involved in meddling in the
elections in any way shape or form and
from what we're hearing the Russians
have denied this but this is the type of
president that takes a problem to lives
it directly to the person who has the
solution for it and pressed him very
tough to find out if Russia had anything
to do with the outcome of the u.s.
election and for what Vladimir Putin has
said the answer is no because that's
mixed signals right so in court even
while trumpeting I push Putin very tough
would announce this is what Putin denied
it I guess we're done here
I guess we're done here nikki Haley you
an ambassador she was on the sunday
shows and she says precisely the
opposite everyone knows Russian medals
you know what I understand is that
President Trump let him know that look
we know you did this and cut it out and
President Putin is never going to admit
that they did it and so they have to
come back and they have to defend
themselves this is Russia trying to save
faith and they can't they can't
everybody knows that Russia meddled in
our elections everybody knows they're
not just meddling in the United States
elections they're doing this across
multiple continents and they're doing
this in a way that they're trying to
cause chaos within the country and
tonight and I guess it's not a big deal
right again these mixed signals are not
useful to the Trump administration if
you want them to get past all of this
smoke and fire garbage then they need to
stop sending mixed signals this way
again Trump said that at the beginning
of the day he said we trust the Russians
and we wanted to December security in it
with them and then nikki Haley goes on
TV inches won't ever trust Russia it
doesn't mean we ever trust Russia
we can't trust Russia and we won't ever
trust Russia but you keep those that you
don't trust closer so that you can
always keep an eye on and then keep them
in check and I think that's what we're
trying to do with Russia right now well
no not so much that's it's not actually
what's going on what's happening is
actually some discombobulation in policy
ash Carter the former president actually
who's Secretary of Defense under Obama
but well Obama was trotting around being
an idiot ash Carter was actually trying
to take care of defense he says that you
know this idea of a cyber security unit
is really done this is like the guy who
robbed your house proposing a working
group on burglary it's they who did this
and so was it a mistake for the Trump
administration to buy it well I don't
think they can buy a we should that's
that that can it's fine to talk to the
Russians about lots of things it's never
talking to people it's a matter of what
you say okay so the new chunk bottom
line is that this vagary is not paying
off for president from now so I think
there's something deeply nefarious is
going on I don't and I'll explain what I
actually think is going on inside from
Ted and what I think is happening inside
the administration but for that you're
going to have to go over to Daley
wired.com right now and subscribe and
you can see we have these beautiful news
studios that's why we just upped our
subscription rates I've been warning you
for a week so we're going to up to our
subscription rates we now have it's
$9.99 a month
$9.99 a month gets you access to this
show gets you access to the mailbag on
Friday gets you access to Clavin the
show it also gets you access to a
brand-new show which will be launching
the next couple of weeks we have plenty
of good stuff coming a lot of great new
material that's available only for
subscribers plus if you wanting at the
annual subscription you get a discount
from $9.99 a month instead it's 99 bucks
a year and you get that's pretty good
discount and if you come any annual
subscriber you get this magnificent
ashed
hot and cold thermos mug
yeah it has leftist tip for the you
should be able t percent left this tears
hot or cold so love it it carries the
right here so yes there it is left this
here is hot or cold pretty magnificent
and it is etched and shiny and beautiful
you get that with an annual subscription
right now you will enjoy it or if you
just want to listen a little later then
go over to iTunes or SoundCloud and
check us out make sure you subscribing
to this review we always appreciate it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
Oh